[Applause]
smelly cat smelly cat
what are they feeding you smelly cat
smelly cat
it's not your fault
it's the stuff friends dreams are made
of
lisa kudrow belting out smelly cat with
some help
from lady gaga thank you thank you
so great i still think it's better when
it's just me
it is the long-awaited friends the
reunion special dropped on hbo max
thursday and it was stacked with a-list
cameos
hi it's so weird because i was walking
down the street and i just haven't
have my guitar yeah oh my god
like mother monster who stopped by
central perk to join lisa who played
free-spirited phoebe buffet on the hit
90 sitcom
for a little rendition of smelly cat
[Applause]
[Applause]
was it okay um yeah yeah it was really
really good
thank you so much does anyone else feel
like it's 1997
all over again i'm really excited yeah
and if all that wasn't enough to have
you in your fields
the grammy winner thanked lisa for
playing a character
who marched to the beat of her own drum
can i just say something
thank you so much for being uh the
person for all of us on friends that was
the
i don't know if this is the right way to
say but the different one
or the one that was really herself thank
you
and thanks for carrying it along missed
our time
it's so good right it was really
thrilling a little intimidating
and then thrilling e.t recently caught
up with lisa and she dished on having
so much star power at the big reunion
what was it like having them all kind of
in the orbit
they like friends so much no
yeah it was really it was great it was
fun some of the other a-list
friends fans to make a cameo david
beckham
bts kit harington mindy kaling
and rhys witherspoon who guest starred
on the show playing rachel green's
sister one of the most exciting things
was i got
to be in the scene where i'm in the
apartment
and joey walks in and he goes hey how
are you doing
and it was this iconic line and i was so
excited
justin bieber cara de levine and cindy
crawford
modeled some of the iconic looks from
the show which ran from 1994 to 2004.
and while the reunion seemed to be a
who's who of hollywood
lisa told et she was mostly just excited
to see her old friends
shooting that shooting any of it being
in the same room
with these people and getting to hug
them that was the best
and the feeling was mutual e.t recently
sat down with the whole cast and they
opened up about how emotional it was to
be back together on the same set
17 years after the show wrapped how
amazing was it actually to be back i
know you guys are friends anyway to be
back in this set on the set with you all
all together kind of
in this zone again it was the most
emotion i i
i had slept so well the night before
woke up i wasn't nervous at all
just feeling good the first question
like how do you feel i was like
and then started crying over the 10
years obviously we really
grew close as a family and part of the
reason was that
that initial success of the show was
something that no other
no one else could relate to or or was
going through except the other five
actors so
we really we really got close because of
that experience too
all i can say is that there was
something that was
laid down at the very very beginning
that kind of went into our neural
pathways that we
instantly it was in our dna that we were
family we were going to take care of
each other
it's unexplainable but we're the most
grateful
women that i know who have been able to
be a part of something like this
you